handsome guys my name is Hoshino and
welcome to episode 118 of game
programming so today we're going to be
talking about UI buttons ok so last time
I believe we did some progress bars here
and our health could drop and whatnot
and one more thing we're kind of gonna
continue on with our UI elements and
whatnot in designing our user interface
so that it can be awesome so one thing
that we're missing that's really
important is buttons ok and probably
other kind of other kinds of UI images
as well like if we want to display an
icon for example that just indicates
something that would be nice ok but
basically in terms of buttons we want to
be able to specify pretty much any
button kind of configuration so we just
want an area really that we can kind of
click on ok that has certain events as
well so let's talk about how we're going
to design that and put it into practice
so this is like one of those situations
where like c-sharp events would be like
amazing but we're going to have to make
do with Java interfaces basically and
see if we can make something that is
kind of nice and clean so to get started
with this what we're gonna want to do is
probably head over to our UI and take
take a look at how that's done because I
don't remember frankly that's the reason
so if we go into some of this stuff so
progress bars a good example so we
Center UI component and we have a bunch
of stuff yeah ok that's fine okay so
let's just make a new class called UI
button it's going to extend UI
components yes I don't want to word
extends their UI components we're going
to do whatever it tells us to do such as
a constructor good that's a good way to
start with a position and we also want
some kind of an event handler okay
so to make this very simple we want a
private UI button event or UI button
listener we'll call it right that's kind
of like what
Java's convention is I think that
they've got like key listener and
whatnot so we'll just have a UI button
listener and we'll call this
button listener okay now let's make it
so that we have to in fact before we
move on to that stuff I'll just quickly
create an interface that is called that
we'll leave it empty for now I do want
to get some kind of graphics displaying
first so if we go to USB you I progress
bar we can probably like it's a full
round color is something we do need what
we copy a lot of this stuff I'll just
in fact I'll just drag it over here and
we'll see what we can do so that's the I
components okay so set foreground color
get progress so we'll grab that render
we'll definitely grab that doesn't
update we do want update though so why
is there no update I would have thought
to you I can print okay there is nothing
good
it's just not in progress bar okay
that's fine
the reason we want update for all
components not just not just things like
buttons and things that actually
actively need attention every frame is
for things like animations right what if
we want the progress bar to kind of
pulsate or show like some kind of glint
or something right we want to be able to
update that animation so we need to make
sure that it's an updatable object
basically so that's the idea okay
so we also need a size so not all UI
components require a size which i think
is a bit weird what do I mean like
labels and stuff yeah I do think size is
something that everything should require
though it doesn't need to be implemented
but it should exist so I'm just going to
make sure that we do have size over here
so that's going to give that and then of
course progress we don't need so let's
go ahead and set up something like label
I guess you could probably structure
this in such a way that a.m. so that a a
button just is simply like a panel that
contains a label that is possible boss
we're probably not gonna do it that way
I think we'll do it our own way so let's
quickly check out
or excuse me
so what do we have to label with God's
yeah yeah it might actually be a better
idea to just leave the label I'm gonna
use a label because yeah it's the better
idea we'll make it public
we'll make a public void set text as
well which just sets the bottom text so
labeled up set text that's more thing
they will text text just to make it
easier so that we don't have to go
button to label the text equals whatever
whatever we want it to be update is
going to be where we update our button
listener and whatnot oh no where we
outlet where we update that but where we
um process that I want to say and yeah
so for foreground color we don't really
need that because I'm just going to call
label dot render G if label doesn't
equal null because we can certainly have
no labels I mean what if the button is
just an image or something okay cool so
let's see here um foreground color we
don't need that anymore since we're just
using the label and let's see so we
don't need that and we go our text okay
that's looking pretty good to me so what
I might do is go into something like
player which is for the rest of our
stuff is and see if I can make it button
so privates UI button button I don't
know what this button will be yet okay
how does a squat again so button equals
new button alright new UI button will
pop it's okay so the health bar will pop
it under the health bar that makes the
most sense
so we'll say like 10 maybe I don't know
260 maybe that's have this good enough
sighs we don't need to specify probably
should though right we do yeah we will
make it so that we have to specify size
because that makes sense and will
transmit size here as well go back into
super or not and add in one that takes
in size as well okay so at least outside
its size and back in player we'll just
add the size so I don't really know what
we're going for you so let's just say
maybe like this is in pixels but it's
like divided by three so maybe we'll say
like oh isn't it it might not be
actually yeah it's not listen
so we'll say like 120 by 40 or something
I'm going upon which is uibutton no mr.
Tate whoops okay so then we'll just
simply say panel add component button
and I think we're good to go
by twine button okay I've got a button
fill in so we should be able to click on
it right now the reason I added events
and stuff or rather I added that thing
let's just kind of reduce this button
make it a bit smaller okay now it's a
pretty cool button actually one more
thing we do we should do is let's just
set a text of it something like hello I
think that'll be there might be actually
be white and it just crashed as well
which is fun labels null okay so that's
bad um if label know how we're gonna do
this this is where active comes in
actually so every UI component should
have a protected bullying active
I'll make it public so active whether or
not something is active so by default
it's going to be true so all that
happens is that the reason that's much
better is because we can have stuff that
exists but doesn't actually do anything
why would I comment that out I don't
mean to do that okay what do we need to
label we need a veteran string so vector
will be something like the vector will
probably be like position dot add like
name four five I'm not sure string will
just be blank so instead of us having to
be like let's delete label on this
record label and we'll have to
constantly basically create objects in
one line instead of doing all that
because that would be bad and efficient
we can just say for example over here
if text is nothing right then we'll just
simply grab our label set active to
false and return or in fact instead of
that we could just do else like that
okay so that's the plan and then by
default it I guess it'll be false if we
use this constructor and don't specify
anything so that'll be the plan update
yeah this is where everything will
happen but if we run through this okay
so that just failed that's a bit weird
because oh I see
okay so position no that's actually very
weird that's very weird why is that case
when we made a bomb we set a position
this little position because he uses the
offset right yes so label so offset huh
so why does it get the offset from the I
guess it gets it from panel so we added
to the panel
not this panel weirder to the panel and
then an up more in the update method
it sets the offset of each component
that it earns to a certain amount but I
guess that doesn't happen for our labels
since this owns it or not
the other thing whoa this is interesting
this is interesting
yeah that's a bit annoying I don't know
how we're gonna fix that easily
yeah we'll think about that we'll think
about that so let's yeah yeah that's a
bit of mine
okay let's kind of change something real
quick let's come into here and so you're
better has been a panel okay
so we'll add a panel and how do we in
our panel not this panel and how do we
add things so add components okay so
what we'll do is we'll kind of do the
same thing with it with entities where
we call the NIST method so it panels
will the things aware of what's going on
the reason what I mean this is you'll
find out in a minute but components are
in there this okay so let's just I meant
that
let's create the method here it is let's
drag that up to be over yeah and then
we'll just say uy panel dot no whoops I
mean this top panel equals panel okay so
now we're aware of the panel the reason
this is good is because now instead of
adding this label to here
which will still keep actually will make
the label we'll set it to false and then
we'll add it to the panel okay and now
we get the offset and what not working
and then we can still control it here
because there's still got the reference
so that should work maybe maybe not
panels null a well then that's a bit
weird
where's our panel I know why okay we
need to do that at image then it was at
public or what was it it's public yeah
public void in it I'm actually just
going to make its default
I don't want it anywhere outside this
package so we'll grab an ant's will
override it we'll call the super init
obviously and then we'll simply say now
what was a paneled hot add component
label brilliant so there you go
I forgot the fact that it's wrong again
and also it's now a different color
which is also brilliant so we didn't set
a color so let's set a color I guess the
default color will probably be for
button I mean I guess I'll just make it
kind of gray maybe like black gray and
oh okay I don't know why it was that
kind of color serious business okay so
the text is too pink well guess we'll
just set
that's because of the font a wolf what's
the default font so default font is
elevator it's going to be that color
okay so that's just color I see so we
should just be able to set the karlon
label dot color equals you can we just
run set color I think that's the thing
right yeah okay we'll set it to
something like if this is the case then
I guess we'll set it to something maybe
a bit dark oh whoops that was what just
happened
come back here okay so we'll set this to
something a bit darker maybe something
like laden are like ah six six six six
six I guess that's about yeah again and
we'll officer Florida lot so by adding
five okay so it mmm I say okay so we
need to do some things with the position
here so factor what is it - I label
position LP so we'll copy that first I
probably won't copy it unless I do this
though and then we'll say LP dot x
equals let's see we kind of want to
probably just add for this a Bart - why
we want to subtract or which way is up
again I don't even know man we probably
want to add about the size at the button
no I don't even know we'll have to
figure out some font metrics and why not
to actually size the button probably
based on the label probably in the
future but for now we'll just say if you
specify your own size then it's going to
be basically plus equals size dot y and
we'll see just what that looks like
obviously add LP yeah let's see what
that looks like okay so that's pretty
good
well maybe add a bit of padding so ya
know I'm pretty happy with that
let's make this darker there all right
cool so there we go we've got a bit of a
button going on it doesn't do anything
yet but it renders and it looks pretty
good so that's going to wrap up this
episode of game programming if you guys
enjoyed please hit the like button I'm
going to put out a video every day this
week so you should be able to enjoy much
more game programming so yeah if you
guys enjoyed hit the like button I think
I've already said that so I'll just end
the video here goodbye
you